[Music]
hello YouTube chest lowers my friends
this is grunge in here I haven't done an
attacking game for a while so let's
continue with our fifth game of most
attacking chess series when I see this
game first time the first word come from
my mouth is Wow and I thought that in my
whole life if I can play a single game
like this then the amount of time I have
spent in the chest is worth full the
game was played in the year 1893 so it's
a quite old but nevertheless it fits to
our attacking style the white side is
Rudolph Chau Chak and the black side is
Jacob Warner now to give you a brief
introduction of world charm sack he was
the leading contender for the World
Championship during his time and he has
played some beautiful games in Danish
gambit as well as King's gambit so if
you are a fond of those gambit you might
want to check out those games
there is one point I like to mention
that I haven't done a deep analysis of
this game instead of that what I want
you to do is sit back relax and enjoy
the beauty of the game whites start with
the movie four and black responds
classically with the movie Phi and here
we have the Dennis gambit on the table
with the move d4 black except the pawn
and white goes into the main line that
is the move c3 and black except the
second point here white continue with
the move Bishop to c4 so offering the
third pawn now taking the third pawn
will be too dangerous for black so very
much known to the scenario black decided
to continue his development and play the
move Knight to f6 although this move
attacked the e4 why I decided to play in
a true gambit style while the move
Knight to f3 so he is inviting black to
take either of the pawns but in those
cases Y can quickly castle on the Kings
side and then launch a tremendous attack
to a black king with stuck in the center
so black decided to play Bishop to c5
which is a nation looking move and only
now why decided to capture the c3 pawn
which also protect the e4 pawn he
black play the move v6 so stopping any
fire advance in the future and both the
side castle on the Kings side
now if you carefully look at this
position black has managed to castle on
the kingside and not only that black has
emerged with a clear paano
so if black can manage to develop his
Queen side pieces then white is almost
busted because white is a clear pond
down with not enough compensation so
that's why white has to play very very
energetically I give you few seconds can
you find the move which has been played
in the game
okay the move is Knight to g5 and it
looks like completely foolish move right
because what that Knight is doing it
just attacking the f7 pawn and it looks
like a beginner move where white
sacrifice to peace for a pawn the rook
so very lightly black plays the move at
six and asking a question what this
Knight is doing over here well here is
the answer
white took the f7 pawn so where you
obviously black capture the night and
now the idea is to play the movie Phi
now let's see the malice of this moon
first thing it's hitting the night and
the second but most important thing is
this point is right now pin so black
cannot capture this point because his
own Queen is hanging that means black
has to move the night in the game black
decided to play the move Knight to g4 so
attacking the e-file but now that pawn
goes one step further so now we have a
bigger problem for the plan not only the
rook is attack but night is also
attacked by the Queen so somehow from
nowhere black is in deep deep trouble
the funny thing is if black try to save
the rook so for example if black try to
move the rook let's say f6 then after a
seven which is a discovered check to the
black King and also there is an attack
on the Queen
that means black we lose the Queen so
black doesn't have any time to move the
rook of course after a long thinking
black decided to give up the roof and
play the move Queen to h4 which is
threatening a checkmate on h2
here white capture the rook with the
check and of course black has the only
reply that is King 2fh and now white
defended the checkmate threat very
elegantly with the move Bishop dreadful
so developing a piece as well as
defending the mid and black players the
obvious move that is Knight captures
after so hitting the Queen and if the
Queen moves then black will move the
night away and give a discover check to
the white king here white play the move
Queen to e2 what I like about this game
is every single move has a tremendous
energy and it creates a deadly threat to
the black key
so Queen to e2 it's not a coming out of
the attack but also threatening to
checkmate black on the eh square so once
again black needs to think along now in
the game black players the move Knight
to g4 but instead of that if black
decided to play move such as Knight to
e4 check then what can simply play the
move King to h1 and now there are two
attackers on e4
so black needs to move the knight now
obvious looking moves Knight to f6 but
it leads to an instant disaster after
rook a to e1 and now there is no escape
because white is happening - checkmate
black on e7 as well as eh square and
black cannot defend both of them
so that is why at this point black
decided to play the move Knight to g4
and after King to h1 black has to do
something about the checkmate black
obviously played the move Bishop to d7
so protecting the eh square now I'd play
the move rope to even once again
creating a checkmate threat at this
point there is only one move which can
defend the checkmate clad that is Knight
to c6 after the move Knight to c6 it
looks like black has defended all the
threat but I give you a few seconds can
you find a sequence which can finish off
the black
I hope you find this move that is Queen
to be a jack boom-boom so sacrificing
the whole Queen doesn't matter how the
black recapture let's say in the game
black capture with the rook afterwards
white take the rook with the pawn and
create the another queen so once again
we have a cheque to the king and after
the bishop takes can you see this yep
this Bishop catches d6 we have a double
discovered checkmate
what a beautiful attacking game
if you can finish up your opponent like
this then the satisfaction you get is
beyond explanation well thank you for
watching this video please feel free to
like and comment this video and I'll
meet you soon bye